foreign
[Music]
numbers are going up there okay because
they're probably saying it's like it's
Sunday why are you doing it's on track
though because we didn't have time to
watch a movie that's why
but I still but I still wanted to do a
live stream we had a bunch of stuff we
had to do yeah so we didn't uh going out
with one of them
been uh
fixing the flower beds and [__] around
the front of the house Tom's doing the
flower baby yeah planting stuff doing
mulch
yeah then yesterday we
went to koi one yeah
Went to went to the ate our fill a
protein
punished them for putting all that
[__] boiled shrimp out and a bunch of
steak they put steak out there yeah just
like Chopstick like slices of it
some of it was kind of dry but some of
it was good man it was all a little bit
tough yeah I don't know what cut it was
they were they were hiding what cut it
was but it was good at least it was beef
yeah it's all right yeah it was just
included in the price I punished him I
ate a bunch of that
well like I said I kind of I mean I like
going there um it's kind of a long drive
for us now like it's not as close as it
was to our old house but it's a pretty
good deal because we were thinking about
going to Bemidji but on the weekends
Momiji doesn't have a lunch special yeah
so they have a dinner menu and you're
basically going to pay the same price
just for like one dish whereas if you go
to koiwan like you can pay yeah you know
18 bucks or something like that you can
eat as much as you want and and then you
can pick through it you know all protein
if you're gonna go to Momiji it's going
to be a lot of rice and a lot of
vegetables but that's okay if you're if
you if you swing that way but I like
meat you know
I mean I don't usually I don't um I
don't think I ate anything that was like
carb heavy I didn't get any noodles I
didn't get any rice I didn't get
anything like that I usually just get
whatever fish they have and then if they
have like you know chicken and broccoli
or mushrooms pepper steak chicken
chicken it's definitely I eat some ice
cream they had good ice cream but um oh
and yeah and they had like hot apple pie
too which I think that I didn't notice
that before on apple pie because they
hid it over there like by the squid for
some reason I don't know why it was next
to the squid put a little scoop of
vanilla on there yeah then I went back
and got two little Scoops strawberry and
Cherry ice cream I didn't get the uh the
the green tea ice cream this time but
is good man it's worth it's worth the
money and we you eat once and we ate
early that was probably about just
turned 11 I think right yeah it was like
11 11 30 something like that because
it's good to go early because then
everything's fresh and it's not as
crowded and did get Hunger the whole day
we didn't even eat before we went out
we like we stopped on the way home from
the club like we usually do and I got
like a sandwich and some chips yeah but
that's it protein [__] yeah
that'll satisfy you and I didn't eat
well the thing about it is that you go
like I love going to koiwan but it's
kind of like I almost feel like it's I
can't eat enough to like make it worth
it because you can eat a lot more than
me to be fair and it's like I can eat
maybe like a couple plates and then I
start feeling ill you know what I mean
but it's bad because it's like they have
so much good stuff and I was like oh I
want to try that and oh I want to try
that and it's just kind of like in terms
of volume though you're eating about
what you would have gotten it it
actually a little bit more uh than what
you'd have gotten at momiji's let me
just good it's just it's a little pricey
I mean even though look at the ratings
and I said it's rated like almost nearly
five stars yeah it's like I can't
believe this restaurant is in its in
this location yeah the food is so good
in there yeah like every time we've been
there a bunch of times and they've
always like the food's always good
everybody says you you're kind of it's
kind of overpriced for the size of the
portions
um you know
and there you don't get much protein
people kind of complain like you know it
only had two shrimp on it you know
although I never got I'm honestly I got
um I've gotten several different things
at Momiji I got they have like a now
when they have lunch special that's only
during the week yeah it's more
reasonable that is yeah and like I've
gotten like bento box and that's
actually really good because you get
like kind of a variety of things and
it's not that expensive but I've also
got the kind of um what it what do they
call it where it's kind of like uh just
like kind of the Teriyaki sort of like
steak and then and that comes with like
salad and soup and everything like that
so it was plenty for me to eat I mean
that was 14.99 maybe yeah you can you
can keep it around 20 bucks a person for
lunch but if you don't if you're not on
that lunch menu it's a really good a
good meal they're trying to get 40 out
of you and that adds up man it does yeah
before you know it you know the damn
near 100 100 [__] dinner Bill if
you're for two it's a lot of money well
what koi won did we notice because we
hadn't been there in a while and then we
went there we started going there again
you know a few months ago was that they
used to charge less for lunch they
didn't have they still had a bunch of
[__] out but it's like they had they
didn't have extra stuff though stuff
like at dinner time so they charge more
for dinner but now they just started
charging the same price just across the
board and they have all the stuff out
always yeah but you know they
discontinued Uh crap crab legs yeah you
don't see them anymore
and for a while you had them there and
it for like and you could you could get
the crab legs
for an extra five dollars
yeah that's right remember we did do
that one yeah I would do that I'd spring
the extra five dollars and just [__]
tear it okay I love crab legs yeah but
their crabs too expensive now
it's not same as it was yeah maybe they
thought it wasn't worth it I mean they I
do like that they have a lot of covid
man during covet a lot of that [__]
[__] the supply chains broke down and
I think they stopped doing things like
you know large-scale
transactions for fishing on [__]
crabs you know there's all kinds of
weird [__] that did not reappear after
covid I think I will eventually but it's
Gonna Take Years I mean I do like that
koiwan has a lot of seafood options
muscles and stuff they got muscles they
got boiled shrimp and then they usually
have uh yeah they usually have crab they
usually have like shrimp in like a spicy
mayo which is really good they usually
have
um what do you call them uh
[__] man what are those [__] things
called scallops no they're on scallops
they have what like the Louisiana thing
okay crawfish crawfish yeah they usually
have something like that yeah um they
usually have a couple different kind
they usually have squid they usually
have a couple different kinds of just
like broiled fish like usually with like
sliced ginger on there like white fish
and stuff fish there I imagine they're
not good because I don't think I ever
had them either
they're supposed to be hot you know with
Cajun seasoning and they don't reuse any
kind of Cajun seasonings there
um
I haven't tried them crawfish are not
special for me that's kind of like
shrimp are much better uh
it's a lot of [__] shell and not a
lot of meat and you're gonna get real
dirty
cracking those things open yeah that's
why I don't get them I like them but I
don't get them because and you have to
[__] eat 10 pounds of the [__] to get
full because there's just not much meat
in it most of it's just [__] Hulls
and um I don't know
the seasonings got to be right they got
to be [__] hot
my strategy when I go there is usually
for like an appetizer I usually go and
get like a few boiled shrimp a couple of
mussels and like a little thing of
wonton soup and then some cocktail sauce
and then I'll eat that and then I'll go
back for
then I just go through the one row which
is usually
the garlic shrimp I usually get one pork
dumpling and then I usually get some
mushrooms
and pepper steak and some broccoli yeah
and then I'll go around the other side
sometimes I'll get crab rangoon but I
didn't yesterday because I was like so
they didn't have crab but then I came
back and said they had crab they don't
have the crab legs what they do is they
have these little blue crabs yeah they
got deep fried right they got I don't
know how to eat them things I was
thinking about that too I'm sitting
there going um there's not much meat in
a blue because I was gonna I kind of
went and I was like gonna get it and I
was like wait I don't want to be sitting
there like figuring out how to eat that
and I don't think they were soft shell
crab if they're soft so you can eat the
whole right that's what I was thinking
because I'm sitting there going is that
soft shell so I can just pop it in my
mouth I don't think they were either if
it was soft shell crab they wouldn't be
up there because those are expensive you
got to get them while they're molten to
get a soft shell crab and they're
they're they're they're expensive that
was just regular old blue crab something
that you use in gumbo if and really if
you we're using Gumbo all the time it's
mostly seasoning you can't get much meat
out of one
worth it it's not even worth it well
that's why I like those big giant crab
legs because at least you can get some
meat out and then they have like Asian
versions of shrimp but they got the
whole shrimp and they'll deep fry the
whole thing and I guess you just eat the
whole thing the whole thing but I think
I think that's what they do but yeah you
can't bring myself to do that I still
peel them yeah yeah I mean I know it
won't kill you to eat the hull but it's
like I just man I'm just I'm just averse
to cracking through all that car all
that damn chitin yeah I don't really
want to do that and I just I feel like
it'll probably just like give me an
upset stomach yeah you know what I mean
so I like eating hair or fingernails
yeah so I like I always peel them but
like I said I do like that they have
that they have all of those Seafood
options because I love seafood and we
don't buy it a lot at home no like we do
have you can't buy it for that deal
that's what I mean so I always like load
up on yeah on makes you want to go back
there yeah I'll go back we'll have to go
we'll have to go back next weekend like
I said it's kind of a drive but uh you
know you guys can look at koiwan in in
Florida and and pull up pictures of it
it's in Altamonte Springs Altamonte
Springs you walk in and it's and it
looks like a Japanese street it's got
storefronts It's got a damn
little Koi pond and a little river and a
little fake bridge that goes over it
and a bunch of Buffets at hibachi grills
and [__] like that and you can get sushi
and Chinese food and just whatever some
American food there and then when you go
into the stores that's the dining area
so it has kind of a theme park feel to
it it doesn't it's a restaurant but it
has a theme park feel you know it's got
It's a cool restaurant it's a massive
it's massive yeah
yeah they have like a lot of parties
because they have like so they're so
scared to go she's people get sick in
Chinese she's the food phobia
people getting sick she was scared to go
I mean she never had food poisoning from
all kinds of different food I don't
think it's like specific to one Cuisine
yeah she was scared it just depends if
somebody like you know wiped their ass
with their hand and they touched your
food that could happen anyway I don't
know man those Chinese people and you
know maybe they don't know how to run
this restaurant kind of dirty and it
says man that's all Mexicans working
back there we talking about
that sounds like [__] that my grandpa
used to say like back in the 80s that's
from [__] up Michigan you know that's
like some [__] people they used to say
like 30 40 years ago she's an ex-vegan
so I'm like nobody says that it's like
she's an ex-vegan so she's scared of
eating food food with meat and stuff but
she's eating it now I had her eating
shrimp she's like oh that's good yeah
she loved it she loved it she goes yeah
this was a good idea to come here
because I can just pick whatever because
you could pick what you wanted because
they have a million different things and
they end yeah
also have a bunch of stuff like you know
if you have picky kids or whatever that
just want chicken nuggets or french
fries or whatever they have that [__]
too she pictured at a little place and
the food just sat there for hours no no
man that shit's rolling well it's a bit
they have a high turnover it's always
crowded yeah so it's like they're always
putting new food out like all the time
nothing sits there though every time we
go there it's mostly people from Central
America whole families are all dressed
up they got little kids look like
they're coming back from church and
stuff and they're just [__] tear that
[__] up tear it up well like I said it's
a good deal I mean if you're gonna just
eat one time that day
hmm I mean you just pay whatever it is I
think it's 17.99 a person or 16.99 I
don't remember how much how much it is
it's less than 20 a person yeah and um
you know and you can just eat as much as
you want and there's like tons of
different stuff they got all they got a
dessert bar they got everything
so you know yeah it's a it's a good deal
if you can eat a lot I didn't know
Chinese food was popular in Central
America but it did by looking at the
people I was trying they're not Mexican
I think they're like from Honduras and
El Salvador uh you know growing up in
Brazil I can usually recognize where
somebody's from if it's in Central South
America but I think they were like
Honduras El Salvador or Venezuela
those areas
but they love that [__] I guess they
have that there I love that [__] too
yeah I guess they have that in Central
America I don't know I think Chinese
food is pretty much everywhere no yeah I
mean it's kind of proliferated at least
like American style yeah yeah I guess
and I think that's kind of the standard
in in the entire American continent yeah
because uh you know there's big business
Chinese make a lot of money selling that
food
and I guess it's popular everywhere I
had I have to ask Connor Watson you know
what a Chinese restaurant is like in in
Mexico it's probably the same
is here probably
or close probably yeah I think he I mean
they were digging into it like they were
familiar with it it seems like they have
a lot of even like a lot of those little
Standalone Chinese because we have a
Chinese place like right down next to
Momiji actually are in the same uh strip
mall that's called what's that called
China Chef China Chef yeah
um but and it's funny because a lot of
these places that open up they all look
exactly the same in there they always
have like the same menus like with the
same pictures on them and stuff like
that so I guess it's kind of like a
franchise model and you can just kind of
like
call it whatever you want because ours
is called China Chef but the one by our
old house was called China Star yeah and
I've seen yeah and they're all like
pretty much the same yeah it has
something to do with Chinese government
Chinese Chinese government-owned
corporations that Supply their those uh
those Industries or those restaurants
a Chinese family will move here then
they have a relationship with these
supply companies that send them stock
photos
stock menus it looks pretty yeah because
the menu is like oh they very they look
similar the only thing the only thing
that's different is the address is on
them yeah like I said you just buy like
a franchise pedal yeah and I think they
I think it's kind of like a franchise
but you change the name of it yeah to
fit your own purse person they don't
care what you call it right they call it
all something different yeah they're
usually killed in China
this and that China Walk Two China Wok
five you know depending on how many of
them
but the food is all the same pretty much
pretty much the same and it's all pretty
[__] decent yeah because the China
Chef we get food from China Chef down
here all the time because they're like
real quick and you just you know I just
order online and go down there and pick
it up and um you know I they're chicken
they're what I usually get like chicken
with cashews and I've gotten the egg foo
young there before it was really good
I've had Chinese American Chinese food
all over the United States man
California
New York Boston
all out throughout the South and it's
all pretty much the same it used to be
you know what I mean against people in
New York they're proud of their Chinese
restaurant oh you can only get this man
the best the best shiny okay the best
General so's chicken which I love
General Social the best general sales
chicken I ever had was in Heidelberg
Mississippi
it was better better than anything
and I couldn't figure it out I
I kept buying it and I said man this is
[__] what is different about this
and I was going through the recipe and
it said you know well mostly hosting
sauces that's what gives it that flavor
and hosting sauce is like Chinese
barbecue sauce
and I was thinking
and the hosting sauce must be different
you know so I said
they must be getting a different
supplier in Mississippi and I was
tasting it and I was going to wait a
minute hold on
that's not hosting that's barbecue sauce
yeah so that's what they were doing it
was Chinese people running it instead of
using hosting sauce they were using
barbecue sauce maybe cheaper cheaper
easier to get cheaper and easier to get
in Mississippi and it was better I I you
know I loved it I was like man that is
[__] great
I mean I'm not a huge fan of General
Tso's chicken so I'm just well I mean
it's good but it's not I don't usually
get it so I wouldn't probably be able to
discern you know yeah I'm not a
connoisseur they got some kind of an
American barbecue sauce probably some
hunts or Heinz a Heinz barbecue sauce
yeah that was sweet baby raised that was
close to to like uh to the whole scene
right close to it
uh probably would be like some kind of
smoked sweet version or something and
they went with that
and it
[__] made it great [__] General
and here's the thing there's no recipe
for General Tso's chicken
the original recipe is forgotten only a
couple guys know it it was from some
Casino in uh in Taiwan
every time you you get General Tso's
chicken
it's a copy and it's not the original
recipe
and there's a whole
movie made about general's chicken me
and Jenny saw it yeah it's fascinating
it was fascinating yeah only a couple
guys alive know what it's supposed to
taste like and they were going nah they
were like no that's not it no that's not
it that's the difference what's the
difference this I can't tell you they
won't [__] without to kill you it was
it's a
it and it's it's it's it's a casino
restaurants
house recipe they won't tell you what it
is
he says there was a couple of them he
said we're close but that's not it
see that's like fascinating it's always
fascinating to me like where these sort
of iconic dishes come from because
remember when we were watching Remember
Gordon Ramsay did that limited series
where he went all around India and
cooked with people and he was talking
about butter chicken which is one of the
best Indian dishes ever yeah but butter
chicken
originated from one hotel right yeah
like one Chef made it yeah and so like
everybody has their own variation and
they get on it they mostly get it wrong
but to be honest even if it's they're
all good they're all good yeah I've
never had a bad butter chicken even even
Ramsay wasn't sure what it was what the
original tasted like and when he had it
he goes oh okay yeah because that's it
because yeah that's it and and he he
wouldn't say what it is either he
wouldn't tell you what it was yeah I
guess that's like because it's it's
classified
he said it's a lot more milder it's a
lot milder it's not as Tangy as as uh
well I like I like the tagginess I like
a milder butter chicken but the Tangy
one's good too I mean we've experimented
with a lot of different
uh spice ratios yeah like in seasoning
mixes for butter chicken
um honestly I think the because you know
how you when you go to the Indian market
and they have like all those different
brands of yeah spice mixes the cheapest
one's the best one it is it's called
Shan Shan is the best one better chicken
Nationals okay too it was a little uh it
was a little spicy or a little dry for
me I think but like the Shan is the best
one yeah and it's not Indian it's
Pakistani yeah uh you can get it the
seasoning mix and a damn paper it's like
a yellow bag in it it is called Shad
butter chicken brand butter chicken
seasoning mix
and that's the best one yeah that was my
favorite one and it's probably nothing
like real butter chicken but it's
they are they're all similar
but I guarantee it's nothing like the
original butter chicken from the Taj
probably not but that [__] seasoning
mix is [__] the best one to me well
it's it's the best to me like I mean you
know everyone's palette is different I
guess but to me it has like the best
balance between being really rich and
savory and it's not it's mild but it has
a little bit of a kick a little bit of
heat but not so much that it's you know
overpowering yeah it has like a good
balance and I don't think the original
Taj butter chicken had any heat to it
which is fine like I said I like Boulder
yeah because remember I bought for a
long time ago for Christmas I think or
his birthday I bought him the Gordon
Ramsay Indian cookbook yeah and a lot of
the recipes in there we've tried some of
them out and they're actually like
really good but they are very very mild
yeah so a lot of times like in the
recipe like Gordon Ramsay wrist and I
guess he's doing that just he tells you
they're mild yeah for like he's just
like you know add because obviously you
don't want to make something that's
gonna like burn your [__] mouth off
yeah you know what I mean he's real
Gordon is real sensitive to hot
he doesn't like things that are hot
which I think is weird for a Master Chef
it might be a British thing I don't know
but then again I've heard British people
eat [__] Texas hot chili and [__]
love it well and they eat super spicy
like Indian food too like some of them
[__] love it it might just be a a
Gordon Ramsay thing yeah I mean
individuals are like I don't I don't
like super hot food I like a little bit
I like a little bit of heat a little bit
of a kick but more than that it's like
I'm it just kind of makes me I can't
taste the food I've had some Thai
chicken curry called gangai it was kind
of like uh
it was like a chicken curry with coconut
and red chili this [__] was just [__]
hot as [__] and I loved it and yeah
you'd ask you how hot you wanted it was
it very hot you'd come back to the Chip
And just burn you up well sometimes when
you go to like an Indian restaurant or a
Thai restaurant you have to tell them
it's like not white people hot I want it
like absolutely real hot Yeah
because sometimes if a white person
tells them hot they won't make it as hot
as they would yeah I mean that is funny
because I was you know talking to Khan
caused my my uh my Mexican buddy from
Tijuana we talk off online a lot
and uh [__] trade pictures of [__]
girl's ass and [__] like that yeah it's
like like I said you let me wake up and
I look [__] there's some Mexican
chicks booty you know I'm like okay yeah
yeah I'm drinking I know we're sitting
there like watching a movie and I just
like looking over there I'm like oh yeah
yeah yeah it's just butt but
it's a Latin thing you know growing up
in Brazil I grew up in Brazil you know
for those you guys new to the show I
grew up in Brazil so South American
culture is I just grew up in it it was
booty Centric it's booty Centric but I
mean I
you know ethnically I'm kind of [__]
Germanic anglo-germatic kind of an
unethnic level and we like them top
heavy at the same time it's a TNA type
culture came together you know
um
but anyway uh
I was telling her about the hot sauces I
like there's a Mexican hot sauce I like
um that uh is it's a brown it's [__]
super hot Mayan recipe I got some in the
refrigerator over there and he goes you
can eat that and he goes but your
basically goes but you're white but yeah
yeah what's that one called because I'll
go get it sometimes they had it like
every now and then you would find it at
like Walmart and we were always kind of
because he loves it I can't eat it but
it's like um because I'm just like you
know thank you but uh he loved it
sometimes you get at Walmart but usually
he had a drive up to there's like a
Mexican uh grocery store slash
restaurant like not that far from here
and usually he would have to ride his
motorcycle up there and like get stocked
up and then one of you guys I don't
remember who it was but like sent us a
huge box of it yeah listener sent me a
case of this
and uh which I can't hold my glasses on
there's a the Mayan word for it okay it
is right there oh you're expecting me to
pronounce yeah it sticks a little
something or other
is it still there it used to be written
there cut wait on Cut Bell ill Dix day
something I can't really read it read it
okay he wants oh he's gonna put the girl
glasses I'll put the girl glasses on oh
look how cute
yes the girl glasses on I still in this
light I can't see it that's what I mean
it's kind of [__] dark okay here we
go there you go he's up at the ring
light
now all of your now all of your chat
comments
okay
this [__] here
is insanely hot it is yeah I think
that's the hottest one they make yeah
and it used to be hotter they made
they're making it Milder
uh then they used to make it like 10
years ago 10 years ago I was one of the
few people on the planet that could
probably eat it they've
probably cut it in half the Heat and
it's still [__] hot
but it's uh
it's not Ghostbusters it's habanero
real hot habanero
and it has a very earthy flavor to it
there's some kind of root in there yeah
because you said it kind of almost
tastes like hot dirt almost like hot
dirt
but good like good yeah yeah there's one
way like I said I can't eat that and
honestly like the older I get because
I've never I've always had kind of like
uh digestive issues
so I've never been able to eat I like
food like a little bit spicy like I like
a little bit spicy but if it gets over a
certain spiciness I'm usually just like
one I'm just punishing myself for no
reason and I'm just gonna give myself
really really bad heartburn and a really
really bad stomachache that's usually
what happens yeah so I can't really eat
it like that but a few times Tom has
made like Indian or Thai and like
accidentally like it's like super hot
yeah so sometimes I'll have to like mix
cream into it or
or I'll eat it like really slowly I'll
eat a little bit and then I'll like sit
there and sweat first I had that smoked
ham the bone and a couple pounds of ham
were still on it I diced that up and
made split pea and ham soup today got a
bunch of it down I'm gonna have another
Bowl later yeah I mean that's all I've
eaten is that bowl yeah there's a lot of
ham in it a lot of ham yeah it's
basically like ham soup and also there's
peas yeah and it's um
did it in the instant pot which if you
guys haven't tried an instant pot get oh
everybody loves the [__] instant
instant pot it's good man you get
there's all kind of YouTube there's a
whole subculture on YouTube like stuff
you make in your ass you can do Indian
food in it Mexican food they got they
got a um
a great Mexican girl teaching you how to
use instant pot on YouTube her name was
cookie it's called the name of the
channel is called cooking con Claudia
and she's great she'll all different
kinds of good Mexican
um recipes it's in English you know you
can understand you can understand it
if you're uh any if you're an English
speaker
but they're uh uh connovason recommended
that channel to me and I've every recipe
I've done of her is [__] fantastic I
use her instant pot carnitas recipe it's
[__] real oh my God that is like the
best Carnitas ever I'm yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna attest that I mean you made
good carnitas you made good carneas
before but you made her version and I
was like oh my God this is like on
another cooking Coca-Cola yeah garlic oh
my God the sugar I think it had some
sugar in it no I didn't have sugar in it
it was uh it was Coca-Cola garlic it's
hard to explain orange juice yeah it's
hard to explain but it's just like it's
this beautiful just like perfect balance
of yeah flavors you put a pork butt in
there or a shoulder man it's good when
it comes out it just falls off and then
you uh put it in a cast iron
Skillet and broil it to get the nice
Brown crisp edges on it caramelize it a
little bit and the drippings I'll put
those to the side and then later on when
I'm turning those Carnitas into tacos
you can Ladle some of that drippings on
there on this on your Skillet if I can
get some of that to infuse into the meat
oh that's great man they're real good
but she's got a lot of recipes in there
things you've never heard of different
kinds of gorgetas and stuff
yeah we need it because I kind of feel
like
we I mean we make Mexican baked chicken
we make a lot of Mexican food we make a
lot of Indian food I have made Indian in
recent we haven't made in the entire
time in a while yeah well honestly like
I said my favorite Thai thing that you
make is that peanut Curry yeah like that
peanut
yeah oh well that too yeah what was that
one you made I think you only made it
like two times and I think the last time
you made it was like years ago but it
was like a curry yeah but it was like
very peanut forward yeah I forgot it was
almost like a soup yeah I forgot what
that was I did too I found online but it
was really really good that was like I
could have eaten a whole [__] problem
with the gallon of calories well I know
that but that's why it was we were
eating that [__] back when we were
getting fat okay and oh if you think I
can get you I'll get you [__] fat oh
he was all right I was not you know this
is before the whole bodybuilding phase
me and Jenny were sitting around getting
fat
oh so I'm trying to be a little more
health conscious
um which really man what that boils down
to is portion control
yeah and um but some of that stuff was
very heavy carbohydrate you know well
because I think what the issue that we
were getting into was that you would
make a giant pot of you know like butter
chicken or addictive or something like
that and it's just kind of like we'd
have one bowl yeah and then be like man
that's so good let's have another Bowl
yeah and then we just Laura we have like
two or three bowls and then like maybe
you'd eat another one like later on the
same day and I'm just like whereas now
we would just have one bowl and then
that's it when I had butter chicken
rolling
oh man I was gonna put pounds on you
because uh I'd make a [__] huge a
huge part of it I mean if you're gonna
make it you might as well make a bunch
of like leftovers because you're gonna
eat it for several days yeah and I'd
overdo that [__] man well and and but it
was so good you couldn't stop eating it
well when you had that sham butter
chicken mix that [__] was addictive I
mean I could have eaten that hole I
don't know by myself I don't know what
they put in there it's like the kitty
cracks like Temptations Kitty crack what
the [__] do they put in those I bet you
something as stupid as MSG
that's probably how it is I mean I don't
think the other is I know it's weird but
it's like I don't know if the other cat
treats have that necessarily and it's
like I know they kind of made a
commercial where they were like joking
about it yeah it's like look the cat can
fly because they want Temptation so bad
and I've heard other people like oh I
didn't even know like calling it Kitty
crack they will they would turn their
nose up at any other food once you get
and The Temptations lickums there's
these little tubes yeah we just got
those and you can put that under it's
like a paste
oh she she loves that too oh my God she
loves that and I don't know what it is I
think I suspected something real dumb
like MSG but you would think if it was
just something like that that all of
them would have that they probably
didn't think about it MSG is monosodium
glutamate and it was a Japanese
invention I think it came out of the 60s
maybe 50s and all it was was just a
slightly modified
uh salt molecule yeah it's salt but it's
a different kind of salt and it powerful
food enhancer yeah I mean salt is a
flavor enhancer but MSG MSG is even more
it is even more so and you can put MSG
on anything and it tastes better like
you can put MSG on a strawberry and it
would taste better
probably I haven't tried it well I think
it just amplifies just like salt does
but yeah like salt or lemon juice yeah
lemon juice will amplifier yeah
put some lemon juice on a dam
strawberry Watch What Happens it's just
addictive all that strawberry topping
stuff that you would get on you know or
strawberry pies and strawberry toppings
for your ice cream that's got a lot of
lemon juice in it yeah it's just a Zing
lemon juice and sugar
man you know what I used to love to do I
would make like for breakfast sometimes
I would make some Crepes and then put
like throw some strawberries on it and
then spray it all with lemon juice and
then a slight amount of powdered sugar
and holy [__] that was delicious another
thing that we did
Jenny bought or this week's like lunch
stuff so when she goes back to work all
her little lunch supplies because she
takes her own lunch my little lunch I
went got some little Debbies and got
some small debris small debris
and Tom was over because they had an egg
cap they had a sale they were like three
for seven dollars or something and he's
like look Jenny they have a bunch of
small Peppers yeah yeah
and that may they have one on there man
they've got a new one never seen before
and it's just fantastic it's a Little
Debbie
that is two peanut butter cookies with
peanut butter cream in the middle and
it's almost like it's like our fudge
like a peanut butter fudge texture
because it almost tastes like my mom's
peanut butter yeah they're that big
around they're the size of their mouth
they're like the size of a moon pie
they gotta have a million calories I'm
sure I don't even want to look yeah I
had one and very rapidly you gave me a
bite yeah very rapidly I wanted another
one I had to fight it yeah I don't need
it I had to fight it I'm trying to
they've got to be at least 300 calories
350. I'm that's my guess gotta watch
gotta watch calories trying to lose some
fat
well the thing about it was that I told
you about them a long time ago because
when my last time my sister was down
here and we were at my brother's house
and we were watching for some reason we
were watching this YouTube channel of
these guys that were trying all the
Little Debbie flavors and like ranking
them
um and they had those peanut butter ones
on there I'm like what the [__] I never
saw those yeah they made that up what
was it called
um I don't know what they're called but
that was the first time I'd ever seen
them in the store because
no peanut butter it can't be that yeah
go see what that shit's called it's
probably just something dumb like peanut
butter
pies or something isn't it just peanut
butter pies like oatmeal cream pies and
because I feel like they've expanded
because remember for a long time they
just had oatmeal cream pies and then
they added the Snickerdoodle pies which
are actually which are really good and
then they had a chocolate chip cookie
one and this is the peanut butter but
this is these are bigger peanut butter
cream pies yeah there you go these
things [__] rock man yeah they're
really good oh man like the peanut
butter cookie is dry but that works with
the it works it's not driest moist it's
moist yeah I guess it's soft okay it's
soft I mean dry-ish don't eat how many
calories are there Google I can't see it
let me see hold on probably 420. is that
like 420. okay yeah serving size a third
of a cookie a third of a cookie okay all
right 420 calories for a third no that
is for the whole no for the whole thing
for the 420. so that's a meal right
there yeah
yeah I mean you can it's like two steaks
just use it as a meal replacement
420 calories there's no nutrition in
that that's so I can no I know but I'm
just saying that if you did eat one
you'd have to skip a meal probably the
main ingredient in that [__] is [__]
shortening that's almost that's almost
100 calories more than I thought it was
going to be they're big they're big
though yeah
I love the way they pulled that they
were just oh the serving size is a third
of a cookie nobody's gonna sit there and
eat a third of that [__] [__] no you're
gonna you're gonna sit there and eat
four of those things
what are they trying to pull
Julianne said classic Swiss cake rolls
have always been my favorite small
Deborah yeah I just bought a box of
those because like I said they were
those ones were more expensive because
they're new I guess or they're bigger
um but the other all the other ones the
classic ones were three for seven
dollars at Publix when we were there
yesterday so I got Swiss cake rolls
um butterfly cakes and I think I hit the
Easter [__] right no I got the birthday
cake ones yeah you got zebra zebra cakes
are my favorite I mean zebra cakes and
the variations because they do a bunch
you know they because we got some that
were like spring or Easter or whatever
the [__] and they're shaped like
butterflies but it's essentially just
like a zebra cake and the birthday cake
one is like that too even though it has
a slightly more birthday cakey flavor
but it kind of tastes mostly like a
zebra cake I feel like yeah uh Julianne
Pope is saying that yeah classic Swiss
cake rolls or her favorite yeah that's
what I said I bought this were on there
I bought a box of those yeah yeah those
were there they're not my favorite
favorite but um they're up there in my
time they also had zebra rolls yeah
which is a zebra cake that's in a roll
those are pretty good too I haven't had
them I've only had them once or twice
because usually if I'm gonna go the
zebra route I'm going this way so far my
favorite one is the uh
the the peanut butter bars what's called
Nutter bar no the nutter Nutty Buddy
Nutty Buddy Nutty Buddy yeah those are
good those are good and the uh those
peanut butter that peanut butter cream
pie those are those are really cool like
I said it tastes like peanut butter
fudge in the middle because my mom used
to make peanut butter fudge a lot now
they had that strawberry roll that was
pretty good that was okay I liked it
love we got the unicorn cakes one time
yeah they're not really nice I didn't
love those I mean they're okay they're
passable I'm not saying the birthday
cake ones were good yeah I got I got
some and they're smaller like they're
just like a little bar you know what I
mean just like one little bar and then
we got some of those ones that are like
that are like that but that are fudge
yeah
they had like I'm a big fan because Tom
was saying last night he's like well
they have fudge rounds I don't like
those
um they're too cocoy for me they don't
really have a lot of they're not all
that sweet I don't know they're just not
that I never really liked fudge rounds
and they also have Star Crunch and I
know that a lot of people that's their
favorite I don't like the star brunch
it's funny we're sitting around here
talking about all this food like we're a
bunch of fatties
[Laughter]
because we're and we're not because
we're not eating it yeah because we're
not eating it I mean I might have a
small Deborah later on I'm not saying
that but yeah
but we're talking this way like we're
sitting around just getting fat Jenny's
Jenny's in training man she's doing good
she's doing weight training weight
training for two days impressed just
she's at beginner level
and uh she's doing good man she's doing
good
she's uh
her metabolism's in the right place
where
she's gonna make [__] decent progress
too
um she's gonna like it she's gonna like
it [__] I accidentally turned her off on
on on on on train and years back I put
too much weight on her too soon I didn't
really know what I was doing as a as a
trainer you got to start with well she
always yell at me and like kind of made
fun of me for being a woman and it's
like that's really not the best way to
approach things with me the second you
start like being a jerk or you start
like you know making fun of me or
something I'm like yeah I'm out
[Laughter]
I don't need to be somebody to you know
come on do a maggot I don't respond well
to that yeah you see the problem was is
that
um I was
you immediately try to go for heavy
weights and real low reps you know what
I mean where like you know 10 you know
five to ten you put a bunch of weight on
it or they can't do any more than five
or ten
it's better to do reps we're like 15 you
know three sets of 15. well it's hard
but not yeah torture yeah and by the
time they get to repetition 15 they can
do it but they're probably not gonna be
able to get 16 or 17. you
because it starts wearing them out you
start them slow like that and then they
get stronger
and within a few weeks there's more
weight on there and their form gets
better you know and um then they start
seeing progress and the other body
starts to change
and then all of a sudden there's
positive feedback you're like oh okay
this does work because the average
person that gets in a gym is not used to
seeing any results they're used to going
in there and [__] working and getting
tired and nothing happening and then
they give up because nothing happened
you know the maybe they were in there
for a month and nothing happened yeah
well like it wasn't happening quick
enough nothing happens quick enough
right well
there's ways around that especially if
you're older gear you could go on gear
what's your answer for everything yeah
you're on here if you're on gear [__]
you know if your testosterone levels are
a little higher than normal for you as a
person and you're on some gear effort
feels good and once that [__] starts
kicking in
it it becomes like oh okay I understand
how the the mind-body connection starts
to increase and you get kind of like a
you know it feels good to me effort
feels good it doesn't feel bad I like it
used to so I understand exactly
how regular people are even when I was
in the Army effort kind of felt bad get
yourself jacked up ever ever it feels
really good
but you your hormonal your hormones have
to be the right place for that
and superhuman basically
slasher Fred said one of the restaurants
he used to go to was Johnny Rockets I
kind of feel like they still rock it
they have those don't they is that a
chain I know I've heard of that I've
never I don't think I've ever been to
one but I mean that's the thing though
it's like honestly
I got to a point where
um you know in my 30s
um I was really really overweight
and um so I basically dropped
about a hundred pounds
and so I got kind of got used to not
eating as much because prior to that I
just ate whatever the [__] I wanted to
you know what I mean and it's like when
I first saw Jenny this was a long time
before we ever went out
she's fat yeah well she's a cute fat
girl yeah yeah
I mean you know I'm not like I'm not
[__] real thin now obviously but and
then um
made friends with her back then
and then she went through a divorce
and she lost a little bit of weight and
then then all of a sudden she fell off
the radar for a while and all of a
sudden I saw her again she came back she
was [__] dead and hot
it's like overnight I knew who she was
ever nobody else knew who she was nobody
else recognized her yeah because I
looked totally different yeah they
thought she just appeared out of nowhere
like she was new
I ain't really seen anything you know I
was like I was like [__] I've been
coming here for yeah
later on once everybody got to know her
in the ways that she because she got
real popular real fast after that
um
she was just kind of invisible before
even though she was super nice just
people know me paid attention she was
married and you know married women are
just invisible
especially if they're overweight
but then all of a sudden once they've
everybody started to know her over a few
months they remembered who that was yeah
they're like oh that was you and they're
like yeah yeah
but she must have lost 90 pounds I think
it was 90 or 100 yeah
I mean now when you and me got together
I gained some of that weight back
because of the butter whole butter
chicken
and pizza and pizza using it yeah you
made a lot of pizza well you still make
pizzas well we were getting older too so
the metabolism couldn't fight it all off
and I mean and I was still I was going
to the gym and everything like that
because before we moved in together I
lived in an apartment complex that had a
gym and I used to go to that gym all the
time but it's just kind of like you know
because I worked at night so I would go
during the day like when no one was
there so I did used to eat but there
came a point where we were just eating
so much that I couldn't keep up you know
what I mean so yeah so I did gain a
little bit back but I mean I was at one
point I think I was on well I was maybe
250 pounds what do you think
[__] that much yeah that was before I
knew you Pro I think so because I think
I had started to lose a little bit prior
to that but I think that's at my highest
I think I was about 250 pounds
yeah
it was funny because
we started hanging out
and we were tearing up the scene we were
good friends we weren't going out with
each other not at that time no we had
messed around but we weren't going out
with each other we were dating other
people
during that time she probably weighed
110 pounds probably
when you say you probably weighed at 110
right no my lowest I got to was 118.
118. that was my ass that's close yeah
what's the matter I don't have time
I'm doing okay
118 that's near 110. yeah and eight
pounds so 120. yeah yeah that was that
was my little you look totally different
I did yeah that's super strong it took
me a second to [__] recognize you I
was like what
and you know I mean I did that yeah I
was going to the gym and stuff like that
but I what what what's the matter
oh my God I mostly did that by
starving severe calorie restriction yeah
like I I didn't
um I wasn't like anorexic or nothing
like that or bulimic or nothing but um
because I have relatives that were
anorexic so I know about that but I
really had to watch it because like I
said and this is this is the same thing
my siblings are like this too it's like
we have very very slow metabolism we
can't get away with [__] man I see some
people like I watched videos online it's
like this is what I eat in a day like
skinny [__] right like this is what I
eat in a day I'm like dude if I ate that
much I would weigh 400 [__] pounds
how can you eat that yeah it's like you
know even if you're working out and
stuff like that I just can't get away
with it like other people can but my
metabolism is super yeah now if you're a
woman
this is not me you can actually do your
research and find out
the closer you get to around 40 the
the more weight you're going to put on I
mean most people start gaining weight
when the older they get I mean it just
happens right and it's just because you
just your body just doesn't make the
the averages it's much harder to keep
much harder that's for sure so
um I'm not recommending this but many
doctors will recommend who are into
hormone replacement is a woman should be
taken
I think it was uh 20
milligrams of uh testosterone a week
which will help keep weight off
uh there are some other things on there
that people recommend I'm not
recommending this other people because
I'm not a doctor other people will
recommend things like internet
disclaimer disclaimer other people
recommend things like NPP which is
nandralone
um it's one of the natural own uh
[__] short Esther neander alone
it doesn't put as much water retention
and I take that I take NPP right now I'm
on NPP I love MPP it's like Trend but
without all the [__] nasty without
all the crazy without being a psycho
without being a psychic yeah we were
talking about that last night at the
club you're gonna take those you can't
just sit around you can sit around and
just take tests as long as the levels
aren't that high it'll help keep weight
off
if you work out
it's even more effective it'll amplify
its effect
you cannot take NPP
things like MPP uh
and and not lift you must do resistance
training
and build a beautiful body every it'll
round everything up just going on MPP
everything on me got more round
everything's just more round than it was
and it only takes a few weeks
and you've got to live though you got to
do the work
but the body starts responding
you know better than it ever did when
you were even a teenager
are there side effects yeah you can kick
a lot of people's asses that's another
side effect uh you can get very
aggressive but she can control all
things like that I mean hopefully right
when you're on HRT or hormone
replacement therapy it's like a license
to take things like MPP you can jump on
and off without any kind of negative
effects because you don't have to worry
about testosterone suppression
so
things like this are best used after
middle age when you're young
unless you're a professional athlete you
don't you usually don't eat it I
wouldn't advise it no it depends on what
you're trying to do if you're trying to
be a professional athlete yeah
yeah you know because
you can make millions of dollars but for
just random [__] yeah not
you're right if you want to be a
bodybuilder yeah
but if you're just random no
no mental hit adrenopause
40 you know if you wanna
feel good and look young then go on HRT
then you can touch up with other things
and some of the listeners have done
taken my advice
and gone on HRT it helps a lot
and women too and
just a tiny bit of test will make a
difference in a woman
who's already been through
menopause you know make a big difference
like look at Jen it's not really aging
normally
and she's older than 50.
yeah most women at 50 don't look like
her
I mean you know she's still got young
guys [__] hitting on her they don't
know how old she is sometimes yeah I'm
just like dude I could be your mom yeah
laughs
gross but yeah it happens sometimes
it's all right
but uh yeah what in about six months
it's gonna happen even more
keep up with that traded
just once or twice a week just on the
weekends okay don't like I come home
from work don't be and I'm exhausted
don't be like gotta do upper body lower
body which you pretty much did that
there's only one exercise that probably
I think you should have done you should
have done um
uh some preacher uh pad arm uh curls
yeah yeah absolutely that would have
that would that would probably maybe
we'll throw some in tomorrow
I'm not gonna be here tomorrow uh where
are you going to be I'm at work tomorrow
oh no after tomorrow's Monday after you
come back and then tomorrow we have to
do the haunting show okay we have to do
the live stream all right then you know
then the day after yeah it doesn't
matter just sometime next week we'll do
some some of that
and um then it just resets
and you'll get stronger and uh you'll
get positive feedback from it you'll
actually eventually be in there so I'm
gonna do this you'll do it on your own
eventually you'll see I know what it is
I went I lived through it
because it feels good
but
um yeah I was gonna say what I was
saying before about
seeing some people like what they can
get away with eating in a day it like
kind of like blows my mind a little bit
the people can eat that much food
because I can't eat that much food and
honestly it's like I'm not even I'm not
thin and like all I eat is
in a typical day I get up and I eat a
packet of oatmeal and a cup of coffee
coffee sometimes like sometimes I just
have coffee I don't have anything like I
don't have oatmeal
then for lunch at work
I usually just have either a peanut
butter sandwich on wheat bread or a
little can of tuna with a couple of
crackers and then that's it and then
when I come home like Tom mold have
usually made something and I'll eat that
yeah but that's it
that's it
yeah Camp guys talking about instant pot
and dried beans hell yeah yeah that's
one of the best things that it's for
like it's really good I kind of feel
like for
um
it seems like really a lot of people are
using like instant pot and like pressure
cookers and stuff like that because it's
really good to like you can just kind of
set it forget it you know what I mean
yeah Camp guy we're talking about the
same hot sauce that's a habanero one
um
the Mayan one that that's what I showed
that shit's good man it's brown
dude I got a brown one the red one
there's a green one then they even had a
damn that company makes a [__] ton of
flavors they had a Caribbean one that
was really good
I kind of remember that yeah you had to
order that special they had another one
that was like yellow it was almost like
a mustard
remember that one that was good too I
don't think I ever ate super hot mustard
I think it was that same was the
Caribbean one hot though
[Music]
it was good because like I said I kind
of am more like in it than my old my
other stuff I can't really eat the hot
stuff it's just
Sergeant deadhead is just saying random
things I don't know what you're talking
about bro I think he's responded he's
responded to things that I said a long
time
yeah I'm not really sure just right on
bro yeah that's right okay well I mean
he's drinking you could just kind of
take it while so away I mean it's still
a week it's still technically the
weekend
yeah give me another one
give me another one it's only 7 30. like
I said all we have to do tonight is
watch a haunting and I gotta take some
notes on it all right and I'll make
these weak okay that's a good idea yeah
cause we I don't well we didn't drink a
lot last night because we went to
Barbarella and they don't have they just
have like the you know the little mixed
drinks and I can't like white claw type
[__] and I have to admit I've tried like
a bunch of those different cocktails and
cans types of thing I do like the um the
gin and tonic ones uh you know those are
pretty tasty but honestly as much as I
love gin and tonic I you know they don't
really love me back I'm gonna say so I
usually can't drink any more than like
two or three and I'm just like yeah I
got really bad heartburn uh so I'm just
not gonna same thing with Bloody Mary's
I adore Bloody Mary's but man if I have
more than one Bloody Mary yeah that's
I'm gonna have a bad time the rest I'm
just gonna be like like the rest of the
day which sucks but um actually I asked
them if they had Bloody Mary in a game
but they didn't
but I'm gonna have to agree with uh with
Tom that even though I don't like
um
I generally don't I'm not a big fan of
Mojitos or I don't get them usually but
the canned mojito that they have is
actually the best one of those
it's we were talking about last night
he's like it tastes the most like the
cocktail that it's supposed to be which
I would agree with that
you know but they I'm trying to think of
like whatever because I got one this one
time I don't even remember what the [__]
it was it sounded good
um on the tin but when I got it it was
cucumber and something what the [__] was
that drink I got that night that was
like in the can that was like cucumber
or lime or something and I was like man
that sounds delicious and then like I
drank it I'm like oh my God this is
horrible yeah terrible
it was a white claw wouldn't it it was a
white or something like white closet
because I know there's a lot of Brands
like that nowadays um and I can't
remember like what the names of them are
but yeah it's like a fancy [__] it
sounded good and I was like God this is
awful [__] dirt it doesn't taste like
cucumbers or limes or anything it just
tasted like ass I don't know
hey Dave's here hey what's up YouTube
we're just you know recovering yeah Dave
the tattoo artist no no Dave uh Dave
from mannequins oh for manic it's okay
yeah yeah okay and he said he went to
man did you actually go to mannequins on
St Patrick's Day because was that a [__]
show it had a better issue I mean I feel
like it was probably a [__] yeah we were
like nah we're not gonna go I was like
no no no no no um I mean other than the
fact that I was like so [__] tired
that I could barely stand up straight
but I mean we went to mannequins on a
Saturday instead because we knew it
would be chilled out just a bunch of old
people Barbara Barbara yeah yeah yeah
and it was kind of It kind of I danced
my ass off last night like you know yeah
like I said we were talking about this
one uh when we took Sophie there
the vibe there is just like a lot more
laid back yeah like you can just it's
just more mature crowds people in their
four yeah it's usually older people I
mean there's some younger people there
too but it's usually like an older crowd
usually most of the people know each
other and have been going there for
years and years over 20 years yeah so
it's like you can go it's 80s New Wave
you know 80s alternative stuff like that
so you can just go out there and dance
and just be crazy and like no one looks
at you funny or you know everyone's like
super friendly and super chilled out and
it's like just a nice
you know you know some hot old people
too man yeah old people their 40s and
50s in there never can't tell what's
gonna happen
that's true yeah
he says I went Friday and Saturday
now Saturday last night didn't they have
like a stripper party or something I
thought I thought I saw like Tina posted
on Facebook yeah give us the lowdown I
was curious to know what happened there
like on St Patrick's Day because I was a
lot of mannequins because Anything could
happen it's chaos it's chaos I love
chaos I thrive on it sometimes it's fun
and sometimes like I said yeah it's a
total [__] [__] yeah I like you never
know which way it's gonna go Jenny's not
[__] up like me
yeah I'm a sane person I can make her
she can get mad you know she did fight
that one guy but she didn't have a
choice you know what I mean well I kind
of he jumped on me dude I had to like
stick my fingers in his eyeballs and
it's like I didn't know what the [__] he
was gonna do yeah and they were pulling
me away and trying to talk Samson to me
and I didn't know what was happening and
then I went well wait a minute hold on
she's under attack no [__] had to
throw people off me and but then they
they said you know the crowd stomped
that dude so fast they're you know well
yeah like I said right you know they
everybody was like yeah that's [__] up
that dude was vanished instantly
well the yeah they picked him up and
took him out yeah like I saw them like
him and he was like and they were just
like yeah they just carried him out the
[__] door I hope they banned for life
I hope they throw him out that would be
super fun I see that dude I'm gonna [__]
him up well we actually when we left
later we we went out and asked the doors
they're like I'm gonna [__] that dude up
I said I'm gonna well I said I'm gonna
stomp him if you don't he still owes me
for that
I didn't beat him hard enough during the
first initial I mean yeah if we see him
walking around you're gonna have to like
drag him behind you downstairs sorry
okay she's highly illegal but when does
that ever stop me Dave said that dude
was there last night he was there okay
I'm gonna [__] that dude oh no he hasn't
learned he hasn't learned I'm gonna
[__] [__] that dude that dude I
thought he was banned yeah this is bad
yeah I knew that wasn't gonna [__] it
I knew that wasn't gonna work he's not
gonna [__] show his face there ever
again I mean like I said or at least not
the same exact face I'm gonna [__] his
face up
Dave said Paul stuck to his venue 13
Vibe I guess on Friday night for the St
Patrick's Day it was weird because a lot
of the newbies there were digging it
yeah that's kind of why
like I said Paul vane I mean he's been
around in or the Orlando scene if you're
from Orlando and you know anything about
like the goth industrial scene from the
80s or 90s like you know who Paul vain
is he used to DJ a Visage and that that
was kind of like the main place that
everybody went and so he DJs at
mannequins now like Friday nights and
Saturday nights and he usually does like
event they still do venue 13 thing which
was the golf club that we had like
several years ago
and so it'll be like
um these are like 80s dark wave goth
industrial mostly old [__] you know what
I mean like some new [__] too like some
90s I'm confused though he said he said
the new people you're talking about
talking about the baby bats or or the or
the Newman or mundanes just walking in
because I know that they have like a
contingent of baby bats yeah as we call
them
for those who are like all who were like
all in like 19 20 21 but they were like
super into this we saw a bunch of them
at the clan of zymox show too and I was
like my little heart was warmed yeah I
was like look at all these children and
they're like all in his eye box that's
so cute yeah they're so little
and they look all like death Rocky and
[__] yeah like big Bohan they do they
look fantastic and I was like that's so
awesome I love that I I was kind of
pissed that they're not coming out to
the club
well like I said maybe they can't afford
it or
no excuse I couldn't afford going out to
Club when you go all the time
I'd be scrimping to go to the club when
I was young yeah
but uh
I like mannequins
I like it too sometimes yeah I mean I
like the idea of it and it's like I like
but a lot of times like I said you never
really know what you're gonna get and I
hold up and I always kind of feel like
like I said when I go to Barbarella
I know everybody there
um you know I can dance I don't like
nobody's like looking at me weird or
nothing like that like you can just like
Let your freak flag fly and it's fine
but it's like when you're at mannequins
there's always like a bunch of randos
and it's like so you never really know I
could just be out there dancing minding
my own business and all of a sudden some
douche bro comes up and it's like
rubbing against my ass or so I'm just
like why is this happening right now
yeah I just want to like chill out and
dance why is this happening yeah like
don't make me because she's talking
about he paid
I'm just saying he paid for that grab
that dude by the throat [__] slapped
his ass right in front of all his
friends and they backed out
you just
and these are six Footers
but I mean was on track like on what I
[__] I'm planning is that okay to
just go up and touch random people yeah
like I said we all learned that in
kindergarten did we not like don't just
go keep your [__] hands to yourself
why is that hard at that time I was on I
was on trend traded test lots of it
I don't even think about it
and uh just [__] just went right for
him and
it didn't matter the dude's six feet you
know I'm
I'm about five six but I weigh nearly
200 pounds and I'm like 13 body fat and
I was on Trend you're [__] amazingly
strong I just grabbed that dude his neck
just felt like [__] jelly
slapped and bow [__] pushed him since
you ever [__] touched my wife's ass
like that I will kill one of your
friends and that [__] shut that [__]
all down when you start holding
[__] hostage over another
[__] I'll kill somebody you care
about and then they just evaporated
they didn't want that that was [__] was
totally unacceptable totally
unacceptable well like I said I don't
understand why people can't I saw that
[__] happen I was just watching just
leading up on the wall watching she
walked behind her you jump [__] Sky
High you what the [__] well because I
was just I was on there dude
[__] touching me and yeah yeah
just like why I don't understand like
why people think that's okay and then
like the the
one that didn't Retreat he was in his
50s
there's another like dude like six one
but these dudes it's like beating up
children they don't have any arms or
anything
I mean they have arms of course
you know
and and he was like well what you know
he was intimidated but I was in total
psychopath mode yeah I noticed total you
know Tran trend is not meant for human
use because of what it does for you what
it does to your head
I have survived it it was like [__]
climbing Mount Everest twice but you're
you're that was uh your view of reality
is extremely animal it was a time that's
for sure
it was the time and Sophie's over here
when I was on it
she said I was terrified but you think
it's totally no no you think it's
totally normal I was just that was one
of the best I mean we love having Sophie
here she's awesome but it's like that
was one of the best things about her
being here was that I had backup that
you were acting like a crazy person
because it's like a lot of kids if I
just tell you you don't believe me yeah
but if you have somebody else there
being like bro what the [__] like then
maybe you'll yeah because you don't
listen to me like when I say it I
thought you were I I couldn't accept it
that's what I'm saying but if I have
backup then you'd be like oh maybe maybe
you're right you're very emotional and
very kind of simpy towards women and
very protective you're you're very
aggressive towards males it is something
straight out of the [__] Animal
Kingdom especially if it's weaker males
or ones that you perceive this week if
they're big and strong you love them you
Vibe with them and yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm joining the wolf pack let's let's go
kill some people you know it's literally
like that you know you don't really say
that let's [__] on people weaker than us
yeah
you know
but you're not thinking about it it's
just happening although you touched my
ass without my consent then yeah you
deserve to have your ass beat yeah now
I've been in fights before and usually
there's a phase where something goes
down you have to make a decision should
I go ahead and use four so that there's
this process you're trying to overcome
uh apprehension or fear and you're
trying to become uh what do you call a
courageous there's none of that on Trend
it's instant just like out of the animal
kingdom there's no it's just an instant
attack
and which is probably why I got away
with so much is because a normal mortal
male goes through a thought process not
a not when you're on shred it's it's
zero to a hundred and [__] 0.5
seconds it's just full on
full-on aggression
and it lit but you think it's normal at
the time that's the thing
and it's not a hallucinogen like LSD
it's hormones so
you don't feel like you're under the
influence of anything it's it's a
strange experience
yeah we were talking about it last night
because you think what you're doing is
totally normal yeah and it's like no no
amount of like telling you that it's not
totally yeah she's telling me I'm like
you're [__] crazy what are you
talking about it's supposed to be this
way this is that you're a crazy person
like you're crazy are you gonna kill me
yeah right now
like I said before there I had no
aggressive impulse I know but I didn't
know that yeah like I didn't know that
no and I was like I was like I went into
like self-preservation mode I'm like oh
my God he's gonna blow my head off no
I didn't know I was totally happy all
the time I felt totally happy but then
I'd get a [__] start attacking myself
like oh man [__] oh you know it's it's
weird it's because your progesterone
levels are so high you're like I mean
yeah because you're like a pregnant
woman well like I do that all the time
but it's like that's just a I guess
that's just a girl thing you
testosterone levels are supernaturally
[__] high you have almost no estrogen
which means you can't sleep real well
and your progesterone is [__] really
high far outside
normal human male parameters and
progesterone [__] dudes up man it it
makes you think like a pregnant woman
so you end up being pregnant Superman or
The Punisher but you're pregnant it's
just [__] yeah he said the last time
it was like pregnant Superman and I was
like oh my God I just had the cutest
like Splash most disturbing like mental
picture yeah of like Christopher Reeves
as Superman but like looking lovingly
yeah
[__] crazy but here's the thing
you're [__] crazy you're probably
clinically insane yeah yeah but you
think you're totally right you think
you're totally yeah instead of crazy
people yeah
looking back on it was kind of hilarious
but I put put everybody else through
hell that's what I mean yeah it was
hilarious for you and not so much for
everybody that had to deal with your ass
I understood what was happening I guess
not so funny for the rest of us yeah
um yeah yeah Dave said Saturday it was
all over the place that's what I thought
and he said that [__] phase came up to
me and says hey man how's it going oh
[__] and Dave said I said hey [__] face
I thought you were banned yeah what did
he say and he said what no they just
told me to go home and not come back
that night I was like yeah no that's not
what I yeah you need to make an
explanation to him that if I kind of
come across him he owes me for what he
did to her all right I'm gonna take it
at his ass
a big chunk yeah I'm gonna take it out
of his ass and I'm gonna make sure
everybody sees it happen I don't care
I don't care
he's dealing with uh you're dealing with
a high functioning psychopath I want it
to be seen
only thing the only thing is I have
responsibilities here that's what I mean
it's like don't go to jail because now
I'm gonna have to pay for this house by
myself
it'd only be a couple days and then hit
the pond out and you deal with the court
system but the thing is is that usually
guys like that won't press charges
because they're committing crimes during
it
like he couldn't come after you because
he attacked you
so that would have come up you're gonna
filed charges against him yeah and it's
like I didn't even like think about it
at the time because I was just like what
the [__] just happened like I was just
so shocked at what had happened he
assaulted you when you said later it's
like yeah you could have pressured I'm
like yeah I guess I could that's why he
vanished and you didn't see anything
about it so you know
usually something like that happens
during during the the event so you can
use legal Warfare
because he's committing crimes you're
committing crimes so let's commit crimes
related to other Society is not involved
in this type of deal
ing Higgins says touching people is just
unsanitary at least for me who knows
where you've been exactly like I said
keep your [__] hands to yourself I
don't know you just might have been
digging in your bottles I'm like I don't
know
um you know not to be gross but Danny
Rowling said uh just seen a sick ass 87
underrated film sorority babes at the
slime ball bowlerama you only just now
got around to saying that oh my God that
was one of our go-to rentals back in the
late 80s Linnea Quigley man yeah we love
Lynette she made a living just [__]
being nude in horror movies she's
[__] hot body though I met her at a
horror convention like a long time ago
and she has like the nicest [__]
person of course I mean of course she is
she always came across as like super
cool
um but yeah she was in a lot of yeah
uh horror movies back then and that was
kind of her thing like she didn't care
about being naked so that they always
kind of like hired her for that but yeah
I actually love sorority babe I don't
think we've ever covered it
um but we probably should at some point
I think I put it in the poll a couple
times but it never won
but one of these days is asking who's
supposed to use it I don't think I don't
I guess he's talking about who's
supposed to use Trev I think yeah
because I think that's what is used in
the cattle industry okay it's for cows
it's for cattle all right
trend is uh is uh
it's basically bull testosterone that
has been modified
into into becoming an anabolic steroid
and they'll they'll [__] put Tran in
cattle
uh
a lot of it to get them big
big muscular and lean especially uh in
like the first in in like a few months
before Slaughter they'll put him on a
bunch of tread
and it it probably [__] them up too but
it doesn't matter they're going to
slaughter I mean they're cows cows are
like that [__] is cheating on me I know
that [__] is cheating that crazy cow
and all the other cows are like bro get
away from her get away from her
don't touch Elsie like that
why is everybody talking about me
they might they might very well be
thinking that yeah yeah yeah we don't
know they're looking at me they can't
speak English so I don't we don't know
we don't know what I'm thinking about no
trans not approved for human use it's a
19 or derivative steroid similar to
nadralone it's called Trenbolone
people have taken it and but it was
never really approved for human use
and that's very effective the reason why
people take it is that it's very
effective it is cheap
especially if you get it from Veterinary
sources okay
um which that's really how it entered
into the scene
I mean you could get a quart of it for a
couple hundred bucks you know what I
mean and
um make dudes big fast but it makes them
crazy yeah and you have to it's a
trade-off yeah it's trade-off
and um
the thing is though is that it's not
necessary there are other ones out there
that'll do something similar it'll just
cost more and take a little bit longer
one of the things about trend is that
it's fast and
a fantastic fat burner
you'll burn a lot of fat off and not
just the fat around your waist or
anything it burns the fat in between the
muscle fibers in your muscles
so you get real dense
kind of compact looking and you get a
good shape
so if you have a guy who's already big
and he's preparing to go to some kind of
competition like a bodybuilding
competition they'll start taking Trend
to give themselves kind of like a freaky
freaky proportions kind of a freaky
definition you know right before
competition
and it'll happen pretty fast you got to
work it's not like you just inject it
and there it is no they're lifted too
but um
it's not worth it I [__] with it and
no it's not worth the money you save and
I'm in no hurry I'm not competing so
it's not like I have to meet show
deadlines or anything I'm just doing it
to look better and get stronger and
fight off aging which people like wait a
minute hold on stero is a fight age yeah
there's a lot of [__] people people
almost everything people believe about
that technology is a lie or not totally
true
um
things change as you get older like I
said earlier that [__] that technology
is better used after middle age
if you're a young kid and you're [__]
around with that [__] and you're using
it improperly at high dosages you may
not make it to 60.
you know
if you're already 50
I mean might as well yeah you know what
I mean [__] your life expectancy is
only another 20 years it's and if
anything uh the guys that have [__]
with it in the middle age have [__]
they seemingly have extended life uh
spans I mean into their 80s and 90s
Danny Rowling also brings up Hollywood
chainsaw hookers that's another good one
with uh Linea Quigley in it that's
another one we probably need to cover
Zach says oh [__] more sidetracks what a
great birthday this is turning out to be
well happy birthday Zach
um yeah we just we only ended up doing a
side tracks because we didn't have a
movie to watch or we didn't have time to
watch on uh Dave says Jen don't let that
prick keep you away I got Tom's back
I'll hold him while Tom punches his neck
[Laughter]
Zach says uh I'd watch a movie about
pregnant Superman I would I would too
not gonna lie
um because of when he brought that up I
was like oh I I like that idea they need
to somebody needs to do that with the um
that's DC right see which one Superman's
DC yeah yeah okay Dad I don't remember
um but yeah I wonder if they've ever
done a um like a DC like a little
spin-off alternate universe series with
like pregnant Superman because yeah now
I'm now I'm kind of like intrigued by
that concept
huh
Dave said even shirtless guy asked me oh
yeah I know surely I know you're sure I
know who you're talking about
um even shirtless guy he's all right
um ask me what the [__] is he still
coming here yeah like so everybody but
that guy knows that he's banned that's
well maybe they should tell that guy
that sure this guy I was on Trend he
almost got punched though because he
grabbed my nipples I didn't know him
like I've seen him around but I don't
know [__] touch me man you know like
I said I don't [__] know you you know
uh Danny really just said just saw the
90s film starring Jeffrey Combs called
Castle freak oh yeah that's another good
one we actually reviewed that a while
back that's Stuart Gordon right I feel
like it was Stuart Gordon or Brian yazan
it was a failed movie commercially uh
but it was pretty good I really I liked
that movie Barbara crampton's in that
too right man we love Barbara crane I
think she what that she looks amazing
and she's like in her 60s I think I'd
hit she looks you did so would I you did
not gonna lie I was yeah I'm just saying
like I saw her she was on um
I saw her very recently I think she was
in that um In Search Of Darkness part
three documentary that's on shutter the
five and a half hour one which of course
I sat and watched like over a couple of
nights because that's kind of dork I am
but um yeah I think she was on that I
was like God damn she still looks
amazing yeah and like I said I'm on her
Instagram too and she's always like
posting pictures she's so cute because
every time she posts a picture she's
always making that cute like happy face
like oh you got it right you got her on
Instagram yeah she's amazing send me a
link I'll I'll follow her on this camera
she's adorable
um I love Barbara we actually attracted
a pretty good size crowd for uh for just
being like a like a [__] sidetration
[Laughter]
um just go ahead and announced that this
is a side track show and um I'm passing
around the collection plate uh the super
chats are active so are what's called
super super thanks super thing super
thanks so if you're listening to this
recorder we got super thanks also and
cookies looking at me like shut the [__]
up look at her face I know Daddy why are
you talking oh my God that was an
expression yeah she's like you're
talking too much
she wants to be petted yeah she's like
why are you talking and I petting me
okay the most expressive face we were
talking about that earlier today yeah
you know exactly what she's thinking
when she looks at you I love her little
mad I call her little mad sometimes
because like if you like if I'm brushing
her because she wants to be brushed and
I'm actually kind of even afraid to say
that word because she knows that word
but um like sometimes I'm doing it and
if I do it wrong or I feel like a bad
angle she totally like looks at me like
yeah like what the [__]
yeah and then she then she takes her paw
and like she tries to do it but she
doesn't have any thumbs so it doesn't
work out
um wait a minute uh
I just saw something that I wanted to
like answer why are you chewing don't
eat the furniture poke okay please you
gotta read you gotta oh Ben says it was
nominally a Lovecraft adaptation yeah it
was um a loose adaptation of the
outsider yeah I think you got to read
David's tale about like a shirtless guy
shirtless guy is the dude that came up
and hugged me so tight when he pulled
away I felt [__] in my ear like ear
juice oh that's right I remember you
telling me that I remember you telling
me okay sure this dude that was the same
night that the fight happened right
because I think I remember you telling
me that that night shirtless dude is
this guy's probably about 60 maybe late
50s
with long gray hair I mean it's not long
long but it's kind of it's kind of like
wavy it's a little bit like um
I kind of feel like it was maybe a
little bit like rockabilly looking yeah
maybe not at one time I think they got a
rocket
and uh he's very thin he's lean he's got
good definition not a lot of mass but
he's got good definition especially for
a guy his age he might even have a
little bit of a six-pack I'd have to go
back and look
but I never really looked at him that
close he can dance yeah he dancing knows
all the good [__] he'll dance to the
Smiths and [__] but he's an old-timer I
think he's a little bit older than us
not by much though but that gray hair
makes him look a little bit older
and um he gets drunk he starts taking
his shirt off yeah and uh I mean pretty
much every time he's done I I very
rarely see him with a shirt on yeah and
then he's got his shirt off
trying to have his way with these
younger women who are not really
impressed
you know
I think he's okay guy probably yeah he's
pushing that [__] a little too far on me
one time and he [__] grabbed my
nipple one time and I almost [__]
punched him only Dr Michael is allowed
yeah
and me he's a qualified medical
physician he could grab him okay
Dr Michael is my friend my friend we saw
him last day and he was at Barbarella
crazy as [__] he's awesome I love Dr
Michael he's actually a veterinarian
he's a vet
and he looks like Riff Raff basically
basically looks kind of like Riff Raff
funnier
because then he's got like his Christian
death shirt on or I think he had an HP
Lovecraft Billy he had black he'll have
a black
uh
uh some kind of Gothic bad t-shirt on
yeah black shorts and like black socks a
lot of times like knee-high socks with
some black shoes and usually like a fish
or like underneath the T-shirt yeah and
then it'll have like [__] fingerless
[__] gloves or fish nets and [__] and
he's got a long hair but he's bald on
top of his head
and uh just kind of this crazy goofy
[__] smile and it smells like and he
smells like Patchouli like he always
like he always smells really good yeah
like because I love the smell of it yeah
he's [__]
omnisexual he's [__] we've known him
forever yeah yeah you he just
if he likes you he's gonna try to [__]
you that's just the way it is but it's
funny
and he has like absolutely no shame no
hahaha
he's super super big cloud you know what
I mean he's super funny and uh he's pot
belly
skinny fat
skinny guy with a pot belly
and he's extremely entertaining and if
he if he if he if he can get him serious
if you ask him a question about
pharmacology or
anything about biology he'll get a super
he'll just beat yeah because I've asked
him like about like about cats and stuff
before because like I said he's a
veterinarian oh yeah he he he he he and
he will just go and he just like let's
see bernality yeah
yeah and he becomes a scientist out of
the [__] blue yeah
you know
we've known him forever he was pissing
me off in front of the clubs in us
I tried to play homosexual chicken with
him and I forgot who he was
sucked this dick then he [__] just
runs straight over there and [__]
gets on his knees
in front of everybody
[Laughter]
he's like wait wait wait I forgot who
you were I forgot I forgot I'm sorry I
can't I can't play chicken yeah because
normally you say some people like oh
yeah but he's like no I'll do it are you
okay that's [__] funny but he'll you
know he he likes women too you know
likes black girls uh likes big fat black
girls remember that yeah that's kind of
that's his stuff yeah he likes big fat
bag he's like a thick black girl yeah I
ain't like him fat yeah he'd sit out in
front of of ibar when it was downtown it
was downtown and you had a
a little uh like like a little patio
like a little patio and the public would
be walking by and he called he he calls
some he'd see a big old fat black girl
because how you doing sweetie party just
start talking to her he'd start pulling
her yeah yeah he stopped pulling her
yeah and I'd be with him and [__] that
he was [__] hilarious you know he's
trying to get a date you know they would
bow out sometimes remember we were
talking that one and I was like no come
on in you know come on in the club you
know she's no I gotta go home you know
[Laughter]
and [__]
Dr Michael's like oh come on
[Laughter]
I'll take care of you he's a charmer
that's for sure yeah he's super funny
yeah funny dude and he's like and he and
he dances like super over the top and
like gosh dramatic and it's like it's
really awesome I love it but see that's
what I mean it's like you you have our
crowd is [__] hilarious Well
everybody's just like characters yeah
but everybody's known each other forever
it's like some kind of a movie so it's
like one big family so it's just kind of
like well that's their thing you know
what I mean so everybody's just like you
you do you you know what I mean that's
what I like about about that whole scene
you know yeah
because everybody you could just as long
as you're not hurting anybody or doing
being an [__] or anything like that
people are just like yep well yeah
that's just how that goes yeah
like super funny
uh Ben said what happened to no shirt no
shoes no entry well he has a shirt on
when he enters yeah he just takes it off
well big Tom big Tom owns the club he's
a friend of ours yeah we've known him
forever this is mannequins we're
thinking about now
big Tom is this uh
uh big old uh black dude who's a Navy
veteran
and uh he [__] loves Morrissey he
loves like 80s yeah like loves
ridiculously
you'd look at him you'd think he's like
a big old gangster but no no he likes
sucking Morrissey and New Wave Music and
uh
he's got a bunch of like white children
who because he's he's married all kinds
of white women over time he's got a new
one now
and uh
he's real uh lacks when it comes to um
like he's from the scene you know he all
his friends are all Golf and [__] so as
long as you're goth you can get away
with a lot in there yeah like I said
it's actually not hurting it hurt
anybody they don't really he doesn't
really care he doesn't care about the no
shirt things oh he's okay we've I mean
people have been like [__] in the
bathroom yeah and they employ you about
it yeah threesomes in the bathroom yeah
we've seen all kinds of [__] has
happened I mean he installed a stripper
pole I mean though kind of the whole
theme of the club is like he started
putting like all these big like sex
dolls like uh like real dolls in there
yeah that are kind of like laying all
over the bar and stuff yeah so he has
that kind of situation going on yeah and
I think last night they had I think it
was like a stripper party or something
and I think like last week they had a
blow up doll party was it last week or
the week before big Tom big Tom was on
the news when that when that his Club
was on the local news here it was it's
pretty good it was [__] funny he
sends me yeah I saw that yeah
because uh the place attracted attention
of the news in a good way they liked it
I mean like I said it's a cool place I
mean he started out his original concept
was
a horror themed bar
and I think I mean judging by the
original Graphics that he had for the
police he called it mannequins because
of tourist trap that 1979 movie because
he had stills from tourist trap like on
the sign that's big talk
wait a minute
we can't see we can't see I mean the
phone's covering yeah his face but you
know what I mean yeah here I'll get some
more
Ben says blow up doll party yeah we did
we didn't go to that but you know what I
mean
that's big time but that's kind of yeah
yeah
but yeah we met him at independent bar
like yeah almost 15 years ago like he
would be he was there every single
Saturday yeah like he asked me to manage
the place and I was like Tom first of
all we're friends you're not supposed to
be working for France another thing is
is that I can't imagine it's a bar I
don't have any bar experience
yeah
but we actually did consultation with
him in the very beginning when they
first before he opened like we went in
there and like about decor and this and
that and
but I can manage a restaurant I can't
manage a bar man that's got its own
[__] thing well and especially like a
nightclub I kind of feel like when you
have all those people in that area and
they're drinking a lot and it's just
like I feel like there are things about
the club
bar behind the scenes stuff that I don't
know about but he's got a really good
bartender who's he he made manager who's
a friend of ours also she can handle it
yeah she seems to be together good job
she seems to be doing a good job
but you know like I said you still got
the random ass people although yeah I
can't believe they let that dude back in
I might have to talk to him about it I
mean I believe it because I was just
kind of like probably no one was paying
attention but yeah you know what I mean
here's a good face shot of big Tom
he's a good dude and you can see it out
there you can uh check out mannequins on
Google
it's it's in Google
yeah it's downtown Tampa Downtown
downtown Sanford
like I said it's a cool place but it's
like when he first opened it up it was
only like half the size yeah and then he
bought the building next door yeah and
tore the wall out
oh yeah look at this Big Tom's Navy holy
[__] look at that there's Big Tom's Navy
picture
hi yeah
but yeah so so now it's like twice the
size as it was and you know
I wasn't sure like when he first opened
it I was like I don't know if this is
really gonna fly or not but when it was
it was small it flew though because it
did he had a lot of walk-in
when it when he got the place next to it
when he got the property next to it and
then merged the two now it's blow it it
it's a blowout if he gets the place next
to that so he's got three it'll be even
bigger yeah because he was thinking
about that yeah he said he still is I
mean when we went I mean seriously we
went there on Halloween that place was
[__] heaving you couldn't even move
in there right I mean in a way that kind
of sucks because it's like we were kind
of stuck out on the patio all night
because I was like you can't even you
couldn't even get to the bar to get a
drink it was like [__] actual of
people but if you ever want to come to
Florida and go check out mannequins uh
just go and uh the owner's name is Tom
Morris you'll see it it's all linked in
there he's a real good dude [__] he's
got limousines and [__] he bought a
couple of limousines and [__] uh
Escalades and crap like that
like I said they do different nights I
know Friday night is kind of like the
goth industrial thing Saturday night is
kind of some of that but then also just
like crazy [__] like I said they'll play
like Abba and stuff too
I think they do a drag show on Thursday
night I think it's Thursday Wednesday
There's a biker night I think on
Tuesdays yeah you should probably go
yeah Wednesday night I think is karaoke
um but I don't know if it's open the
other DJs but I'm pretty sure that's
what they do and I think they still do
the drag stuff on Thursday
I don't know yeah I think they do I
think it's like it's called the tree
house or something like that like yeah
it's like a drag thing but then like
Wednesday night they do karaoke a lot of
people go to that we went to that one
time
but I didn't sing any karaoke though
I have to be really drunk to be like
singing some karaoke oh they're gonna
ask me if you can see Shazam too because
they haven't seen it because I like the
first one um we were talking about yeah
I liked Black Adam too we saw Black Adam
yeah days ago I should probably watch
the end of that because I fell asleep
yeah that kind of was really good I
don't remember what happened at the end
because I just I was so tired and I just
like dozed off
but you know what I mean
um
Danny Rowling said that Adam Driver film
65 was okay but you know what's weird I
was just reading about that
like earlier Adam Driver like versus
dinosaurs I'm just like so behind
I'm so behind on the movies
um let's see Danny Rowling said that new
M night uh Shyamalan film was super
disappointing there was no plot twist
which kind of sucked yeah I mean
um I wanted to see that because I read
the novel that it was based on which is
if you don't know it's not called knock
at the cabin which is what the movie is
called but the book is called the cabin
at the end of the world and it's by Paul
Tremblay and actually I really really
liked the book
um and I don't know
I wanted to see it so I haven't like
watched any reviews of it because I
don't want to get it spoiled or anything
because I don't know if it sticks to the
book exactly it looked like from the
trailer it looked like it was pretty
close to the book but I don't know if
they're going to end it the same or
whatever but the book is really good if
you haven't read it
Paul Tremblay is like a really good you
most people cite um a head full of
ghosts as his best one which that one's
good too but um I I don't know I kind of
like cabin at the end of the world a
little bit better than head full of
ghosts but head full of ghosts is also
pretty awesome
um oh and if you didn't see it I posted
another book review like earlier I just
I feel bad because I don't I can't I
don't have time to like read as many
books anymore and the one that I read I
actually read it entirely like on my
lunch hour from work like on my phone
like on my Kindle and it's like I I
don't know go watch the video because I
have like a really weird experience with
the book that I don't think I've ever
had before
um let's see
how long we've been on an hour and 34
minutes
um Zach said if y'all are ever in uh
Indy I'm assuming he means Indianapolis
you should hang out at Greg's it's the
biggest or oldest gay bar in
Indianapolis and it's some kind of
Distinction wild ass place see that
sounds super fun that sounds super fun I
don't know if it's still there or not we
used to have a really good
uh uh gay bar I think it might still be
there I'm not I don't know but it's
called Southern Nights in Orlando and
um for a while they had like a fetish
party like a goth fetish party like once
a month called Escape
um it was always really fun like all
kind of crazy [__] would happen today
oh okay but all kind of crazy [__] would
happen to that but they stopped doing it
after a while and then like the
sadly
um the the guys that organized it one of
them moved away he moved to LA the other
guy died
um so they didn't do it anymore but I
think maybe the club is still open I'm
not sure but that was a nice place I
used to like go in there like once a
month I can't remember what night it was
what [__] night was it I think it was
like a Friday night I don't remember
it was a while back
today rolling said yeah I hear there's
still glitter residue on the walls of
that place dating back from the 70s yeah
leave that [__] there it's character
it's character
ah we got we went to Barbarella last
night we got there so early like all the
[__] lights were still on they let us
in though because we were like man they
know us and I'm plus Tom was like dude I
really have to go to the bathroom like
he had a piece that was like he let us
in but I was like I don't really want to
come in here with all the lights on
[Music]
um
but yeah it's Ron Weasley get his head
bashed in but oh okay well
I'll see it eventually I do want to see
that I do want to see knock at the cabin
but like I said it's mostly because not
because it's m night uh Shyamalan
because a lot of his more recent movies
I haven't been a big fan of but um but I
really like the book so I was kind of
curious to see
Yes actually that's not the only residue
still there I'm sure
do wood core samples on the floors and
re-release all the plagues
oh [__]
I'm sure that's the thing though but
like I said that's kind of what gives
him character I know if you think about
it it's kind of gross and like not super
sanitary but that was one of the things
we used to say about
when I used to go to the castle uh
regularly which is still there in Tampa
which is kind of like one of the
venerable golf clubs of Tampa and it's
like a cool [__] place it used to be
an old
cigar Factory I want to say there's a
lot of those in Ybor City which is like
the old section of uh Tampa very pirity
very like there was a lot of cigar
manufacturing there and I think it was
either an old cigar Factory or maybe
like an old
and it was like an old like um what do
you call it like a [__] not Kiwanis
but what's that other thing
some kind of Lodge or whatever it was
like an Elks Lodge or some [__] like
that and it has like stained glass
windows and it's like made of brick and
it's like really cool and everything but
it's like you that place is so cool like
when it's dark that it's like the one
time I saw it with all the lights on
like after I was like ah I don't really
want to see it with all the lights on
you know what I mean
hahaha
I don't know
uh Zach said apparently there was a
bartender who'd go there with toys deep
up in there and one fell out of his
thing and rolled across the floor
well no uh no like a toy like a like an
anal thing I'm assuming
like so he would so he would just like
walk around with stuff stuck up his butt
and then like whoops every now and then
like it would fall out and like that's
pretty gross
I was gonna say too when you were
talking about shirtless guy at
mannequins one of the since I brought up
the um the castle kind of the most
famous guy that went to the castle was
the senator yeah dude walk around naked
basically yeah and again that's like you
just kind of got away with it he didn't
come in naked obviously he always had
like a cape or like a coat or something
on but then he would come in he wasn't
he didn't start out naked he would come
in and then he would go in the bat in
the unisex bathroom
and take off his cape and hang it up and
then he would always be wearing like a
baby doll
and like a thong
yeah and he just yeah and he'd go around
with like with his you know with an
erection or whatnot I always thought to
do was ridiculous I'd see him I was like
man he is but he didn't really bother
anybody and everyone he was just kind of
like an institution you know to be
around forever he'd been around he'd
been going there like as long as that
everybody everybody knew this Saturday
everybody and it's like every now and
then you'd see him around but like I
said he wasn't creepy or not really I
mean it sounds creepy I think he's
creepy but he didn't like but he didn't
like he didn't do anything he didn't do
anything to anybody like he didn't kind
of come up and rub on you or he didn't
he just kind of like stood there and
danced you know like in his outfit and
sometimes he had a boner so you know
and sometimes he would just like take
everything off and just like dance
around it but you know but he wasn't
like rubbing his thing on nothing or
nothing like that so if you didn't the
castle is this big [__] fantastic
goth nightclub it looks like a castle
30 [__] year I think it was a masonic
lodge Masonic Lodge that's the word I
was trying to think of I said either
that or it was a it was a cigar Factory
because there's a lot of cigar factories
in that area yeah
and um it's like something out of the
movies it's two floors yeah
yeah it's two floors the bottom floor
has a bunch of different Wings to it
One Wing is kind of like a BDSM Wing
it's like a dungeon it's got cells they
have a fold yeah with cells cells and
everything Central play [__] torture
racks yeah they got torture racks all
over it's massive because they have like
a lot of fetched parties there the walls
are all brick and it's all painted like
[__] black and red with red lights in
there and [__] spooky looking
chandeliers it's you can look at the
castle
you can track them down somewhere on an
old Channel
that we used to have
and there's just all kinds of wild [__]
would happen in there
but then it also just had a regular kind
of cool bar on the bottom floor it was
like something that you'd see like at a
House of Blues
there's House of Blues level quality
the kinda
um and it had outdoor dance floor and
then upstairs you had a big main dance
floor with a bar in it and then another
little rooms with a bar and little
[__] Warrens and [__] with
bathrooms and [__] it's it was it was
it's a cool place they're not gonna have
velvet couches and like I said stained
glass windows and they'd have boxes up
there with some of the goth girls that
we knew up there be dancing it was their
job to dance yeah they had the Go-Go
dancing go go dance Gothic go go dancers
yeah [__] in
basically bikinis with a bunch of fish
nets and boots and [__] massive
[__] hair and
really good outfits you know they
weren't dressed up as guys they're goth
girls
I mean well some of them rushed there
for years yeah professional goth girls
and the one like the famous One her and
her mom owned the um that goth clothing
store yeah uh in Tampa which I think is
still there yeah what was that one
Ravens and Rockers is that yeah what was
that one girl we we knew we haven't seen
her in a long time she was one of the
main dancers there
uh I know I can't I'm trying to remember
I was trying to remember what her real
name was with the [__]
[__]
did we saw her at uh sorry at the
[__] the horror convention visit her
and her mom like they set up a um yeah
man it's been so long since we've
[__] even just talked about the
castle Yeah the castle we went there I
think the last time we went was like at
the vampire ball or fetish ball or
something that was like a few years ago
what was that girl's [__] name I'll
probably remember it like after we
stopped yeah now since we were talking
about the vampire ball I just I just
remembered this morning
uh uh our friend Dimitri
who DJs it vimento Mori he sent a
picture we just saw him Thursday night
to clean his IMAX because he was DJing
at that too and he looked different then
but it's like he sent us a picture this
morning and said look Tom I shaved my
head and grew my beard out so I look
like you now since I look like you now
and I said yeah Jenny goes you can dress
up as each other I was like how funny
would it be if you guys dress up as each
other for Halloween yeah and then I said
actually that would kind of be funnier
if you said that you dress up as each
other for Halloween but you didn't
actually look any different than normal
you just told everybody that you were
the other person I don't know I would
think I would think that was funny yeah
because normally I mean he had he had
hair I don't want to say he's like my
hair but he had like it was all shaved
and then he just had like a little bit
at the top
but he shaved it off next he's gonna try
to get jacked
he might yeah
he told me dude you need to stop working
out I was like what you're getting too
big I'm just getting a lot bigger than
you okay well you know yeah getting too
big man
so I'm gonna put another 20 pounds on
you're gonna get bigger yeah I'm gonna
get bigger
he got mad
he's bad man yeah oh what's his name was
crying
who was crying at the Abbey
dude is it lean up against the wall with
me
he hadn't seen me in about two years oh
never him and his girlfriend he's what
the [__] I just wanted to [__]
touching my leg and [__] Scott Scott
yeah not not the others guys we know
more than one Scott he goes dude man you
look totally different and I said yeah
and he started going yeah we hadn't seen
them in a while oh man
that's a bad idea
[Laughter]
I ain't gonna [__] with these people
though I'm just playing with him Zach
says the only time I Googled the castle
I saw one of those 360 photos of a
chicken fetish gear on a table and a
dude and Joker makeup was grabbing her
boob yeah there's all kinds of stuff
that sounds about right well I mean the
Ben said the dungeons probably left over
from the Masonic Lodge days honestly it
when I first started going there in like
the late 90s they didn't have that
dungeon that was a later Edition
um because I mean I guess it's
successful enough that they could
because it's a big dungeon I mean it's a
whole
half of like the first floor
um but I guess since they started
hosting all those fetish balls and
people come from like all over the South
and all over the country really
um so they Justified
putting like I said they installed
there's [__] there's human cages in
there you can go in cages and there's
prison cells and yeah
and there's like all kind of like um
shackles and [__] like that like just
mounted like all over the walls and
they're mostly not using it it's just
mostly there just for obvious but they
do have fetish stuff happen there yeah
they have like a couple big finish balls
a year and they have a big they have the
big vampire ball which it's not quite as
big as the one in New Orleans but it's
almost as big the one that we went to a
couple years back so if you remember we
went with Dimitri and um we went with
Dimitri and Jen we stayed in that hotel
there yeah and that it was like [__]
packed in there it was like 40 bajillion
people
I mean it was fun but there was like 40
Virginia people it was like super super
packed
um let's see what else
uh Danny Rowling just seen an artsy
1990s Viggo Mortensen vampire film
called the reflecting skin I covered
that
um
a few I just want to say a few months
ago it might have been a year ago but I
think I covered that on my flickers of
fear series interestingly I first saw
the reflecting skin back in maybe a year
or two after it came out like sometimes
like in the mid 90s I want to say and I
think I just happened to see it on cable
and I was like man that is weird as [__]
and I really liked it so I taped it like
back in like you did in the 90s like
you've had the VCR and you taped the
[__] off the TV and so I had it like on
tape for a long time and then like
recently I saw that it was on 2B so I
was like oh I'm gonna review that [__]
because I haven't seen it in a long time
and yeah that's like a really [__]
weird movie
I like it though I like it
um it's like it's very misleading it's
not a vampire film at all yeah it's not
not really
it's kind of hard to explain I'm not
really sure what genre I would call it
but I tend to like movies like that that
are just kind of
I mean it's nominally a vampire film but
not really
but if you haven't seen it I don't know
if it's still on 2B or not it was for a
while
but that's where I got the idea to like
revisit it because I hadn't seen it in
many years
um let's see what else I think that's
all the comments uh Jeffy art said my
ignorance is showing is there a
distinction between the goth versus the
vampire community
um I don't think there is a vampire
Community well down here
there's an overlap
I mean there's a big overlap I'll
survive I'm not gonna lie but no usually
vampires are goth but God people are not
vampires yeah it's that's what I mean
it's like van the vampire thing that's
like a subset yeah
um but most Goths are not into that
hardcore
um because there is a very a small
subset of the god subculture that is
very into the vampire thing not as much
I kind of feel like I don't see it as
much
as I did in like the 90s yeah and the
early 2000s it was very big then I
wasn't into it like everybody's kind of
everybody likes vampires come on but
it's like I I wasn't to the extent where
it's like oh I'm Gonna Get You know uh
fangs installed and all that kind of
stuff it's like I'm not because some
people do do that like they have there's
one guy that um
that I guess he lives in Tampa but he
has a whole business making
Fangs for people so there's like enough
to smash yeah yeah yeah so um
Jen has some but they come out she
doesn't have them all the time some
people have them like permanently yeah
if we can gnash his [__] it's like all
handmade it's Dental quality yeah take
some out of a movie
they're really good they're expensive
though
you could bite somebody with those yeah
probably work yeah they're like super
realistic like I said Jen's got a set I
think she got him from him but she but
they come out like she doesn't wear them
all the time but some people wear them
all the time I don't really know anybody
that's that into it and that if you do
like if you go to the vampire ball it's
mostly I kind of feel like it's probably
like 90 just Goths that dress up like
specifically vampire yeah there's
vampire or there are vampire parties
right kind of thing it's good yeah it's
kind of like a theme like within
you know well like I said it's kind of
like man I mean mannequins does that a
little bit too
um where it's like different Friday
nights they try to do different things
it's like oh tonight we're doing like
you know um steampunk or tonight we're
doing uh post-apocalyptic or something
like that so it's like you can still do
like the goth look but in a specific
sub-genre type of theme you know what I
mean so I kind of feel like vampire is
kind of like that that girl's name was
Sheena that's right yeah why did I
forget that yeah
that's what she doesn't dance there
anymore but that was uh one of the
dancers from
um yeah she's the one that her and her
mom yeah her and her mom run Ravens and
Rockers right that's still there yeah
isn't it I mean I've been there for a
couple years see if I can find but it's
like a goth clothing Sheena in her dance
outfits
let me see yeah I think the last time we
saw her was at the horror convention
yeah
because they had a booth
like because I think I bought some [__]
there too and I bought a skirt and some
other stuff
yeah she always had like really awesome
outfits yeah you'd see her like that up
and dancing on a box yeah she always had
really awesome outfits on
she must have had like a million well
like I said her mom owned a clothing
store so she could just she had like
tons of clothes if I can get a picture
of her dancing Sheffield said I recall a
South Park episode where the goth kids
had a rivalry with the vampire kids yeah
yeah it's like I said it's not so much
that yeah I kind of feel like we were
talking about this before there's kind
of like
overlap between keep talking sorry the
goth community and the fetish Community
but a lot of people that are into fetish
stuff aren't necessarily into goth and
vice versa you know what I mean
but the goth things tend to have like a
lot of fetish events because there is a
lot of overlap I don't think there's as
much overlap
as there would be with like the vampire
thing
because there's a lot of people that are
into fetish stuff that aren't into goth
at all
you know what I mean but
particularly I kind of feel like the
goth thing more overlaps with like BDSM
more than anything yeah like as far as
that fetish Community goes that's a good
dance that's like a steampunk kind of
yeah kind of deal there that she was
doing yeah yeah she always has like lots
of different horns and everything
I she used to have like photos of her
just full length
dancing she had a nice figure
which probably still does it's been a
while since we've seen her
yeah I haven't seen her for a couple
years I don't think
Zach says I have a show topic suggestion
the Final Fantasy house I've actually
been one yeah because I think you
recommended that like a while back and I
kept putting I put it in the polls a
couple times and it never won so it kind
of just went to the bottom of the list
but that is another one that I want to
do eventually that is a picture of her
on the box dancing inside the castle
with the flash lighting up the bricks in
the back
yeah that's in the main room there yeah
yeah that's a it's a cool place I'm
actually amazed that it's been because
you wouldn't think it I think a lot of
people are very surprised yeah that
Florida has a gigantic goth industrial
feather scene gigantic I think she's
selling shots there isn't she yeah yeah
and like you wouldn't think it because
like Florida and everything but
nope we have one of the largest scenes
in the
country they must be doing some kind of
promotion there yeah yeah this is some
kind of promotion for the castle they're
out there with the hearse and [__] out
in the broad daylight
so we're not talking about [__] small
beans it's one of the biggest golf clubs
it's been there for been there forever
at least 30 years no more than 30 years
because I remember they had their 30th
anniversary party and that was like
several years ago yeah so they've been
there like forever
and it's kind of like that's just the
place if you get if you're like a kid
and you get into the god seeing
everybody's like well we have to take
you to the castle it's kind of like they
would talk about a Rite of Passage
there's a [__] famous Saturday Night
Live episode where they had [__] goth
talk remember the guy it was a fake talk
show yeah and [__] Cersei Nightshade
and some other [__] and they were from
Orlando yeah all right and then the
guest the guest of that day was the girl
that played Buffy the Vampire Slayer
yeah and they have her dressed up like
this goth chick and she shows up on the
Fig goth talk
uh [__] show to talk about the castle
and there's this huge fight breaks right
about who had which is sort of accurate
exactly the way it was it kind of is
that's why we thought it was so funny
because we're right here so it's like we
know I mean I'm from here Michelle Sarah
Geller's [__] characters yeah she's
she's going they're up in Orlando yeah
we're in Tampa we have the castle you
know [__] it just it's just it's
doing like [__] goth classism it's
not as bad as it used to be yeah um it's
not really that bad anymore Orlando
upped its game a lot but back then it
was a big deal like I I feel like the
people in Tampa like were snottier yeah
because they were like well we have the
castle so we're obviously better better
than you yeah um you know I mean Orlando
had independent bar that had been there
for 30 something years but that's not
really a goth club that was more like an
alternative Indie because you know they
would do 80s New Wave they would do
indie rock they would do stuff like that
so it wasn't like a goth club they would
have goth Knights every now and then but
they didn't have anything that was like
just for that whereas the castle is just
for that that's their whole thing and so
um so yeah so Tampa people got a little
bit like back in the day Tampa people
got like super Superior and that's why I
thought that was like really funny that
that whole I was like man somebody from
here had to have written that sketch oh
because somebody on SNL came was from
Florida because I was like it was like
so specific and it's like if you're not
from here like it wouldn't make any
sense to you necessarily but it's like
if you're from here that shit's
hilarious because that's absolutely what
was going on and that was absolutely it
was talking about the 90s that was a
different era in [__] Orlando was not
really at the top of the game at that at
that point Tampa was way ahead and they
had the castle Yeah it was [__] that
was one of the biggest best golf clubs
in in the United States and if you were
in Orlando chances are you just drive to
Tampa so a lot of people did I used to
drive to Tampa from Daytona which is two
hours yeah but there's one way they had
little goth nights one of them had been
independent bar yeah at that time and
that's probably what they were talking
about they didn't didn't they didn't
name it in in that episode right uh uh
but that's probably what they were
talking about they named The Castle
though yeah well like I said the castle
Yeah they didn't [__] down Eye bar
because yeah I mean I was awesome it's
still awesome even though they changed
it back to work but with the thing about
it like well Tampa what it would have
been Visage
oh that's right that was long enough ago
that I think Visage was still open yeah
it was it was we had a place here called
The Edge too that was actually pretty
cool that was more I think they had it
as a dance club sometimes but that was
mostly like a show venue because I saw a
40 million concerts there are so many
but um I was gonna say Tampa not only
not only do they still have the castle
now but they have like a bunch of other
places too that have goth bands play
there it's like they have crowbar they
have
um what the [__] is that they have one
that's just called like World New World
Tampa or something like that
um because they do Absolution every year
in October which is a three-day goth
darkwave music festival and they've been
doing it for I don't remember how many
years now they started like several
years ago
because I did all the the logos and the
graphics and everything for it and it's
three days and they have like tons and
tons of bands and it's really really fun
but um but they used to spread it out
over like two or three venues and now
that I think they're doing it all at
crowbar but um yeah so they have more
places but the thing about it is that
Orlando got some more places too I gotta
go check the soup I mean we have uh okay
and um tell them what the haunting
episode is tomorrow yeah I will I know I
see it
um but yeah Orlando has some like we
have the Abbey which you know they have
a lot of shows there where we went and
saw a clan of zymox on Thursday and
um you know we have there we have like a
horror kind of bar I can't remember what
the name of it is but it's on Church
Street so we have like more stuff
nowadays that we had back then but it's
like it was like a big thing for a while
like the whole Tampa Orlando
rivalry which is why we thought that
like [__] was so funny because it's like
holy crap that's like it was like so
specifically tailored to like just be
funny to
like five people that knew about that
and it's like I really appreciated that
they were like that they went that
specific with it
so the um haunting episode we're doing
tomorrow is going to be uh spirits of
the Dead I think we're gonna do that's
from season four I think it's episode
five uh the one on the horse farm I
don't think we've done that one but I
kind of remember that one and I remember
that I'm being okay but I was like yeah
I was going through the list and I was
like that was the first one I came to
that I you know hadn't remembered doing
so you know that's the one that we're
going to
do probably and we gotta go watch it
after holy [__] it's 8 30 already holy
crap yeah we better go watch that uh so
yeah I guess we'll wrap it up Tom had to
go down and he had the soup in the thing
he like heating it up because we're
gonna eat some while we watch The
Haunting
so yeah thanks for dropping by on this
wasn't spontaneous because we usually do
a show on Sunday but you know doing a
Sidetrack show instead of a movie review
but uh yeah so we've been on for two
hours so I should probably log off of
here oh you did come back yeah I'm back
I should probably get off of here and uh
you know we'll eat some soup we'll watch
a haunting take some notes on it then I
gotta start getting geared up for
another work week yeah so you know so
thanks for dropping by everybody hope
you enjoyed the discussion we'll see you
guys tomorrow at 7 30 Eastern Standard
Time and we're gonna be talking about
haunting spirits of the dead from season
four so hopefully you guys can all join
us for that and we'll see you again
tomorrow